the first episode of the house of dragon
has released and she says the thing
now if you're still not sure what this
is referring to let me play you another
clip that might jog your memory
now dracalis is the valyrian word for
fire targaryens like to use this word
when they want dragons to just you know
blow fire on the enemies and just wreak
havoc against everyone or in the case of
house of the dragon for a burial now i
actually knew rhaenyra was going to say
dakaris in the scene but his setup was
just too perfect for it so hearing it
was quite a joy not going to like just a
little bit of my game of thrones self
geeking out and i got to say everyone my
hype for game of thrones is back because
after season 8 of game of thrones like
most people i was very disappointed and
my hype was killed and when the show
firstly got announced to be honest i
wasn't excited for it but once i started
to see the trailers and everything i'm
like you know what i reckon this show is
going to be really good and after seeing
the first episode i was right so let me
know your guys thoughts in the comment
section below did you know rainier was
going to say this and what do you think
of the episode as a whole and you
haven't already please like and
subscribe thanks for watching guys